HE BEAT LA SATURDAY STOPPING 32
GOING ON WHEN HE JOINED US AND
HE HAS SHAVED IT ALL OFF.
WEARS 75 FOR BYRAM, OH, YEAH,
THE OLD DEFLECTION ENDS UP G G
BOWEN BYRAM, NUMBER FOUR, AL.
THIS IS A HECK OF A CALL BY WENK
IMMEDIATELY AND GREAT SENSE.
AND COVERED NOW BY THE BLUES
GOALTENDER.
WHAT A SAVE POUNDS
IT.
TERRIFIC LEGS THERE EARLY ON BY
BOZAK.
AND THEN KYROU AGAIN.
NOW PARAYKO,O,ONE, TO
THOMPSON, IN ON GOAL, AND THE P
KILL HAVE BEEN ON THE BENCH. PL.
NOW FOUR KAUT, THAT BLOCKN BY M
AND HE KEPT IT IN THERE. CAN'T
THERE IN TIME.
AND IT GLANCES SHOT TAKEN BY
MURRAY, AND GRE LODGED TIGHT
AGAINST THE WAITING.
IN FRONT.
ONE-TIMER.
BINNINGTON GOT LOST HIS STICK A
YOUR BALANCE IS JUST A LITTLE
OFF WHEN
TOREY KRUG TRYING TO SHOVEL IT
AND NOW DAKOTA JOSHUA.NOW THAT
NOWHERE TO GO WITH 19 YEAR OLD
.
HE WASN'T HAPPY, MUMBLED A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND, YOU  YOU
JOE FF DEEP IN THE ZONE AFTER
THE ICING CALL.
GOOD PLAY BY TOREY KRUG. DRIVE M
UP HIGH.
STOPPED BY BE
THAT LEADER ON THE POWER PLAY MG
HOLY JUMPING, WHAT A SHOT.
BUT THIS PASS